what are the advantages of a biden
health care initiative versus what trump
has
i mean and taking his word for it is is
a hard thing to do
but going forward where where are the
key differences
well we don't know what trump would do
on health care over the next four years
so what we do know is during the
campaign trump said that during his
first year in office he would replace
obamacare
um that that didn't happen obviously
obviously um
the two proposals that republicans put
out
would have led to depending on which
estimate you look at
24 to 32 million people losing health
care coverage through a combination of
it becoming less affordable
reducing access adding ways for health
insurance companies to kick
people off etcetera now a few
month and a half ago donald trump said
that within two weeks he would be
signing a new health care bill into law
it didn't say what was in it didn't
happen anyway
so i think the problem with comparing to
what we would see under trump is we have
no idea it would probably be nothing
like
the ideas have so far been so bad that
he probably would get nothing done
yeah but if he got the things done that
he's tried so far it would be very very
bad 25 32 million people would lose
health coverage
what joe biden wants to do is to start
with obamacare as the framework
and add a public option that's expected
to pull down
premium prices uh industry-wide a little
bit
and in total uh i i'm trying to remember
the numbers it's
if you add up all these different things
somewhere around 25 or 30 million more
people will get coverage
part of it would be through additional
subsidies part of it would be
because the public option will be
cheaper and people will be able to
afford it
biden has talked about being in favor of
lowering the medicare age from 65
to 60 or might have even been 55 so
you know you add up all of this stuff
and about 30 million more people will
get health care it's not bernie's plan
but if you say david listen the two
options are 30 million people lose
health care
or 30 million people gain health care
that's a delta of 60 million i know
which one i'm going with right
yeah absolutely and is there a place for
caution or criticism in the in the
amount of influence that the health
insurance
and pharmaceutical companies have on
policy and law lawmaking
of course absolutely yeah i mean listen
um we some countries don't have
for-profit health insurance
health insurance companies are
non-profits they're run almost like a
public utility in some sense
um so of course yeah and that applies no
matter who's president
yeah yeah and that's i feel what a
libertarian would say and i've had
libertarians on this show
is that that would stifle innovation
that one of the greatest things about
having a for-profit health healthcare
system is that we are more innovative
than other countries is there any
real truth to that or is that something
that's just another
fantasy that's fun to believe well
much like with a lot of these
libertarian fantasies
it's everything is shades of grey right
yes
so it is true that uh
there are aspects of how things are
organized here that lead to
innovation as it's called at the same
time there are countries that are
organized in other ways that have also
had
innovations i mean you look at china you
look at cuba you look at russia those
are countries that are organized in
other ways
they have the power of the government
deciding hey we're doing this thing
and then they go and they do it now i'm
not a socialist i'm not a communist i'm
not advocating for those systems i'm
merely pointing out that these black
white ideas
often fall very short but i think the
more interesting
conversation is if in the end
the innovation is happening at a
for-profit company
it's happening because of
government which is there to establish
intellectual property law
and enforce it it's there because of the
u.s postal service
and public schools which a whole bunch
of the employees who are doing the
innovation went to i mean you know it's
this is why we call them libertarian
fantasies because they ignore
that okay cool jeff bezos did x but
he did it with 50 000 employees educated
in public school
mailing stuff around with the u.s postal
service with contract law
enforced by the judiciary i mean you
know it's like
i love that take that's hilarious
now the libertarian libertarianism is a
really it's a fun
rabbit hole to go down and it is really
interesting but it seems almost
like it would work in oklahoma if
oklahoma was a sovereign country
with however many you know 30 million
people maybe and it it
it has legs but at scale it just does
not it just does not hold water
in at the level i don't even know that
it has legs and it's i mean it's like
you what you basically end up with is
instead of government and and sort of
consensus being the governing body
you have whoever gets the most guns the
quickest and
i don't know that that's better right i
just don't know that that we're actually
better off if that's the case
and you know the reality is that there
are certain things that are too big for
anybody but government to regulate
effectively the idea that well
this town is is regulated in this way
and this town is regulated this other
way because these people had the ar-15s
and nobody else did and eventually
that's sort of like what it comes down
to
there are certain things like
multi-billion dollar corporations
really only government can effectively
regulate them across a country or across
the world that's the reality of the
globalized
planet we live on